[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la mine de ça vous regarde ce soir
l'angoissent des juifs de france
moqueries injures agression 84 % des
18-24 ans affirme avoir été victime
d'actes antisémites c'est le résultat
d'une étude publiée hier la négation
d'israël comme état est une nouvelle
forme d'antisémitisme déclarations d'
emmanuel macron au premier jour de sa
visite à jérusalem alors que de facile
dans le pays ce mal est-il incurable
c'est la question du grand débat ce soir
le chant du coq le bruit des cigales ou
encore le tintement des cloches
d'églises à l'accueil des municipales un
député veut inscrire le bruit et les
odeurs de la campagne au patrimoine
rural alors pourquoi en sommes-nous à
devoir faire une loi pour protéger les
sens même de nos terroirs nous poserons
à la question au député pierre morel à
l'huissier qui porte ce combat et puis
notre grand témoin ce soir est un vieux
de la vieille en politique longtemps
chiraquien puis sarkozyste il a failli
céder aux sirènes macro nien à paris
aujourd'hui il soutient rachida dati sa
meilleure ennemie
claude goasguen est avec nous ce soir
voilà donc pour le programme sans
oublier une petite surprise à la fin de
cette émission avec l'astronaute préféré
des français vous savez tous ces partis
on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir claude
goasguen
bonsoir et merci d'être notre grand
témoin on a une heure à passer ensemble
bourges revient dans l'actualité on va
revenir sur la visite des manuels
maquereau en israël et dans les
territoires palestiniens
avec déjà quelques séquences mémorables
on parlera aussi de la campagne des
municipales mais on va commencer avec un
sujet grave avec ces nouveaux chiffres
édifiants sur l'antisémitisme en france
le quotidien des juifs est devenu plus
que préoccupant on en parle ce soir avec
vous pierre birnbaum bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes historien
vous êtes aussi sociologue professeur
émérite à l'université paris 1 panthéon
sorbonne et vous venez de publier la
leçon de vichy une histoire personnelle
c'est au seuil ouvrage dans lequel pour
la première fois et bien vous racontez
vos années d'enfants juifs d'enfants
juifs cachés dans une famille des hautes
pyrénées
vous êtes spécialiste de l'histoire des
juifs français à côté de johanna barras
bonsoir voir déléguée adjointe à l'adil
cra en charge de l'éducation la disgrâce
et la délégation interministérielle
chargée de la lutte contre le racisme
l'antisémitisme et la haine anti lgbt je
rappelle que ça dépend du premier
ministre un ça dépend de matignon marine
refait bienvenue à vous je vous êtes
enseignante professeur d'histoire
géographie et vous avez longtemps
enseigné à drancy en seine-saint-denis
vous travaillez aujourd'hui au conseil
départemental du 93 enfin j'accueille
avec plaisir sofina ou bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes réalisatrice et
depuis trois ans eh bien vous êtes
lancés un peu dans une course contre la
montre un projet qu'on pourrait croire
un peu fou recueillir la parole des
derniers survivants de la shoah en
france il en reste une petite centaine
ça s'appelle les derniers c'est une
série documentaire on enverra un extrait
des programmes courts plutôt destiné aux
jeunes générations c'est en accès libre
sur youtube et pour cinq épisodes on
peut aussi les voir sur france 24
et vous en avez également fait un très
beau livre les derniers c'est aux
éditions allisio voilà donc pour les
présentations celui qui va comme tous
les soirs ouvrir cette émission 7 ce
soir ils nous plantent un un état des
lieux de l'antisémite
le cst femme et son billet si j'ai bien
compris tout de suite
[Musique]
myriam bonsoir messieurs bonsoir
stéphane blakowski bonsoir alors si j'ai
bien compris ce soir n'en parlez si j'ai
bien compris il ya une montée de
l'antisémitisme en france 1 c'est pas
nouveau il ya une manif il ya un an pour
dénoncer ça et hier il y avait un
sondage paru à la une du parisien fait
par l'ifop qui nous dit qu'un tiers des
juifs qui vivent en france se sentent
menacés quotidiennement ça veut dire que
tous les jours que dieu fait quand vous
vous levez en france et vous êtes juif
canadien qui se disent mais on va
m'emmerder simplement parce que je suis
juif alors on peut se dire c'est du
déclaratif
peut-être que les juifs exagère ils sont
un peu parano est bon en fait non il y
aussi des chiffres les chiffres de
l'adil cra alors c'est un acronyme un
peu compliqué mais ça tombe bien vous
êtes de l'adil crabes dont vous nous
dites que ça veut dire c'est la
délégation interministérielle donc
rattachée au préfet vient de le dire à
la lutte contre le racisme
l'antisémitisme et le vhc pour la haine
anti lgbt donc voilà s'est attaché au
premier league donc c'est les chiffres
officiels qui en font des statistiques
qui nous disent que donc en en 2018 ya
eu mille soixante trois actes
antichrétiens en légère hausse par
rapport à 2007 mais assez stable il ya
eu aussi sans actes anti musulmans alors
ça c'est le chiffre le plus bas depuis
10 ans et puis il ya eu 5 141 actes
antisémites et là ça représente une
augmentation de 74% par rapport à
l'année précédente
c'est évidemment plus que préoccupant
alors moi aussi je trouve ça préoccupe
myriam mais alors figure donc on n'est
pas si nombreux à trouver ça préoccupant
bah non non non canwest vous assurent
ils dans le sondage de l'ifop donc que
publie le parisien tout n'est pas publié
dégâts sont regarde les chiffres
complets on m'a demandé aux français est
ce que vous vous êtes personnellement
préoccupé par la montée de
l'antisémitisme
ben non non la réponse est non je vous
laisse regarder les chiffres 62% des
français sont pas personnellement
préoccupé par cet antisémitisme et donc
nous on dit dans les 38 % mais c'est
comme si l'antisémitisme finalement été
une empreinte qui concernait que les
juifs mais grosse erreur de penser ça
mais non mais de se penser surtout pas
ça d'ailleurs le président de la
république tu es ce matin à jérusalem et
il a fait une déclaration sur le sujet
en écoute l'ombre noire de
l'antisémitisme se répand rené et cet
antisémitisme
revient à chaque fois que les
démocraties sont malades que les crises
sont là et ne concerne pas simplement
des juifs mais notre destin commun et
pour ce qui est de la france toute la
république
voilà pour le diagnostic présidentielle
au fond le retour de l'antisémitisme
c'est le symptôme de la crise
démocratique est exactement bien je vais
vous dire les juifs c'est comme les
canaries alors je sais ça ne se fait pas
de comparer duluc aux animaux il ya eu
des précédents malheureux mais attention
les canaris le cannabis quand même pas
des rats ou des pieuvres comme dans les
années les plus sombres de notre
histoire plus en plus c'est pas moi qui
ai trouvé la comparaison que les canaris
c'est le rabbin delphine horvilleur on
écoute et on utilise très souvent cette
image du canari dans la mine que vous
connaissez peut-être qu'on dit que les
miniers lorsqu'il voulait savoir si une
mine et etc ont été condamnés envoyez
des canaris lorsque le canari s'arrêter
de chanter c'est que la mine était été
condamné qui avait une fuite de gaz
toxique et vendent bien souvent et juifs
ont joué ce rôle dans l'histoire
lorsqu'il s'arrête de chanter lorsqu'ils
sont menacés
quelque chose qui les transcende est
menacé alors d'où vient cet
antisémitisme comment l expliquer eh ben
on revient aux sondages puisque on est
parti sur le sondage on a fait une pause
au milieu sur le sondage en conclut sur
le sondage c'est logique
alors on a demandé justement aux juifs
l'échantillon juge par de litote
selon rich étaient les principales
causes de l'antisémitisme en france donc
c'est eux les premiers exposés c'est
logique qu'on leur demande d'où vient le
lait cause alors numéro un
l'islamisme mon sens on s'y attendait un
peu quand même 2002 ont là-bas des
enfants dans une cour d'école en france
13 ans plus tard lippert cacher ben
voilà on n'a pas de grosses surprises
numéro 2 2 les préjugés anciens
bon ça ça prouve qu'on n'a pas attendu
les islamistes en france pour être
antisémite
ça existe depuis longtemps il ya un bon
film de polanski qui s'appelle j'accuse
sais pas si vous l'avez vu sinon paul
eluard numéro trois sur le podium
l'extrême droite qui doivent être un peu
déçus ils ont longtemps été premier l'on
trahisse ils ont perdu la médaille d'or
mais en même temps marine le pen est pas
antisémite donc c'est normal qu'ils
perdent un peu d'aidé place du
classement puis après pour les accessits
il ya un an 4 les réseaux sociaux alors
c'est vrai que c'est nous même occasion
de se défouler de faire son pivot me
quand on a une vie pour id de se venger
et donc souvent sur les vit depuis en 5
arrive l'extrême gauche qui est un peu
le nouvel entrant dans le classement
parce que les juifs ont sans doute le
sentiment où l'on éprouvé en tout cas
que l'on confond parfois antisionisme et
anti
sémitisme tout simplement donc c'est
lors de la conclusion et vous le savez
myriam la base de la pédagogie c'est la
répétition alors je vous le répète quand
les canaris arrête de chanter et ben
c'est climbing va bientôt exploser donc
c'est pareil pour les juifs si on menace
les juifs c'est que ça va bientôt
exploser
merci stéphane et beaucoup de choses
dans dans ce dans ce billet je vais
commencer avec vous pierre birnbaum on
va on va regarder à nouveau ces chiffres
un tiers des juifs de france 34 % se
sentent menacés dans leur vie
quotidienne en raison de leur
appartenance
c'est six fois plus que dans l'ensemble
de la population alors on est sur du
ressenti si on prend ce chiffre là mais
ça reste est édifiante
si au delà du ressenti puisque quand on
regarde dans ce même sondage les
chiffres sur les actions soixante dix
pour ça
bah c'est donc au delà du ressenti c'est
la réalité des choses et ce chiffre est
assez surprenant tout de même que 70 %
de cette population ainsi défini de
manière assez ambigu enfin le la
définition des pâtres très juste très
très précises est un chiffre immense et
révèle la poussée de l'antisémitisme
tels que la commission de
des droits de l'homme du ministère de
l'intérieur le raid la révèle depuis
longtemps alors il ya une différence
entre les actes et la poursuite y met et
les actes et la perception aperçu sets à
1 70 % c'est les actes aux victimes
d'actes anti sol et son cours de sa vie
ce jeu presse ce qui paraît important
c'est bien celui-là distinction parce
que henry était très souvent dans la
perception les choses sont moins fortes
si l'on regarde cette ces rapports de la
commission nationale on voit que les
français ne sont pas antisémites que
lisa il il accepte tout à fait je pars à
80% de leur enfance marie-eve des juifs
à 80% que l'or le présent de la
république soit juif dire qu'il ya
énormément de sondage qui montre à quel
point il ya eu je n'ai pas ce n'est pas
contradictoire
les sondages montrent que la population
française dans son ensemble ne partage
pas un grand nombre de préjugés pourtant
ces mêmes sondages révèlent à quel point
les anciens préjugés c'est à dire les
juifs ont beaucoup d'argent
les juifs ont beaucoup de pouvoir sont
très présents 60% à peu près dans ces
sondages publiés par ministère de
l'intérieur déclare qu'ils ont trop
d'argent autre pouvoir
alors est ce qu'il ya un lien entre ces
préjugés et ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
ce sondage dit plutôt le contraire
parce qu'au fond ce que montre ce
sondage c'est la peur du monde islamiste
a fallu de nos concitoyens mais de
culture musulmane est au fond la la
minoration très surprenante de la menace
d'extrême droite
il me semble que cette menace d'extrême
droite est très forte masse et les
sondages vous l'avez montré lé on
pourrait on peut retrouver la chine le
chiffre est la proportion il me semble
qu'elle est beaucoup plus présente dans
les actes que dans la perception par les
villes de france
et si l'on regarde les rapports de
police alors que l'antisémitisme qui ne
sont pas diffusés points mais auquel on
peut avoir accès on voit à quel point
les actes d'origine d'extrême droite
sont en progression et juste me dit un
incident inédit sur l'heure n'est pas de
statistiques ethniques puisqu'on parle
en france ce sujet là on se demandait ce
que c'est pas le nouvel antisémitisme et
du déclaré l'islam est en fait en
allemagne ça existe donc il ya vu un
reportage sur france inter j'ai écouté
aujourd'hui qui disait que 70% des actes
antisémites en allemagne sont commis par
ce qu'il appelle des blancs caucasien
donc il n'y a pas forcément l'idée que
ce soit
rattaché comment ça va dans le même sens
et si vous comparez non seulement la
station allemande glaciation américaine
on voit que pittsburgh qui me paraît un
événement considérable dans l'histoire
juive de siècle en siècle
c'est la première fois que 11,8 secondes
tu es aux états-unis 1 h abattu et de
juifs aux états unis que jamais dans
l'histoire américaine
on a tué un juif en 1912 en tant que
juif il a encore ce sont des gens
d'extrême droite qui viennent de tuer
des juifs dire que ces sondages et
cerveau forme de décalage entre le
ressenti en même temps sur les juifs
tués récemment dans les attentats voilà
c'est à dire c'est plutôt le le monde
d'origine islamique qui se manifeste
alors johanna barazi un autre chiffre
parce que quand on parle des 70 % c'est
l'ensemble d'une vie ça ne le relativise
pas du tout mais quand on regarde la
jeunesse 84% chez les 18 24 ans là où le
chiffre explose et c'est beaucoup plus
récent dans une vie comment vous
l'expliquez alors il ya plusieurs
plusieurs éléments déjà je voudrais
avant de répondre directement à votre
question revenir sur ce chiffre de 74 %
d'augmentation à l'année dernière qui
est pas précisément un chiffre d'il
craquer les chiffres que sur lesquelles
se fonde la dite ramé qui sont des
chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur
bien entendu mais ne produit pas
directement de mesures est sûr sûr sûr
les sur les jeunes je pense qu'il ya
plusieurs plus vieux qu'elle génération
qui est née bien sûr avec ça une
question il ne connaît que ça d une
question d'exposition évidente puisqu'on
parlait de la de la dimension
quotidienne de ces agressions de ces
agressions ressenti donc on parle du
chemin de l'école on parle de
l'université et on parle de l'école on
parle d impossibilité d'être exposé à
des phénomènes y compris de groupes y
compris de harcèlement qu'on a beaucoup
vu est-ce que nous exerçons beaucoup de
choses derrière
le mot actes antisémites chien ça va
quoi de de l'injure à la menace jusqu'à
l'agression les chiffres distingue les
actes et des menaces de manière
statistique un peu particulière mais ça
va effectivement de dégradations de
biens qui sont qui peuvent être à la
fois des actes et des menaces si on
prend un tag par exemple c'est à la fois
une dégradation un acte et en même temps
c'est une
c'est une c'est de l'ordre de l'injure
de l'ordre de l'ordre de la menace ce
sont des micros agressions quotidiennes
des des insultes qui ne sont plus cette
fois ci sur les murs mais directement
adressés à des victimes
donc on parle d'acte c'est important de
bien noter on a une forme
d'antisémitisme qui salit les murs de
nos villes qui se reprend au cimetière
qui qui qui barbouillent des murs de
d'élus parfois et puis plus sympa plus
préoccupant mais tout aussi préoccupant
est extrêmement angoissant pour les gens
on parle d' agression directe physiques
qui peuvent aller de bousculades à du
harcèlement répétées et puis évidemment
et ces dernières années on en était
malheureusement et de manière absolument
dramatique
les témoins on parle aussi du pire et on
parle aussi d'assassinât comme une série
est-ce qu'on tue plus en france parce
que on est juif qu'ailleurs parce qu'on
pense à mirek nole à sarah halimi on
pense aux enfants de l'église au haras
torah de toulouse où pense à l'hyper
cacher on peut pas faire c'est que ces
comptabilité morbide de pittsburgh fait
nombre de victimes qui fait évidemment
qui transforme les les événements en
tout cas on tue en france parce que on
est juif on l'a fait à deux bien trop
nombreuses reprises de cesser ces
dernières années et on le fait
enfin le fait ça témoigne de d'une forme
d'antisémitisme évidemment
particulièrement violentes et
inquiétante et qui est encore une fois
je voudrais juste sur le fait que ces
agressions a évidemment quand elles
apprennent ces formes les plus graves
elles ont des effets sur les personnes
qui sont sans commune mesure avec des
agressions qu'on dirait banal en termes
de destruction de son de l'estimé de soi
en termes de conséquences psychologiques
et physiques on parle de choses qui
parfois même en termes de dissimulation
quand on regarde c'est ce même sondage
puis ensuite on parlera de l'école 43%
évite certains quartiers 37% et vite
d'afficher des symboles 33% et vite
d'afficher un style vestimentaire 25% de
révéler leur appartenance pour vivre
heureux quand on est juive vivons cachés
au bc transfert de population sont de
son fait à paris moi je vois bien dans
l'ouest parisien la population juive qui
augmente d'année en année
parce que parce qu'elle fuit en réalité
d'autres départements qui sont plus
difficiles
le 16ème 17ème levallois neuilly
boulogne sont en train de constituer en
fait espèce de refuge sens péjoratif de
la communauté juive qui salent à ses
intérieurs oui c'est ça un petit peu oui
c'est ça et qui fuit en réalité la seine
saint denis où les agressions sont venus
ils ont peur quand ils sont partis parce
qu'ils ont peur ils ont la possibilité
comme en général ils ont des moyens
parce que tous ne peuvent pas venir ce
sont des quartiers qui sont relativement
chers mais la peur l'inquiétude
moi je voudrais signaler aussi que le
phénomène d'antisémitisme est mondiale
et c'est vraiment la nouveauté
l'angleterre connaît des poussées
antisémites effrayant regard des
dernières élections si le parti
travailliste tenant des propos par son
leader exonérations qui sont
véritablement des propos antisémites qui
devrait être sanctionné et qui serait
que sanctionner en france marine rester
quand on revient jean luc mélenchon
jouer peur je voulais pas m mélenchon
ben moi je vous aide un peu marie-rose
et perdons pas moins un tout petit peu
de l'école parce que sur ces 84 % sur
les 18 24 ans on se dit que forcément
c'est dans l'environnement scolaire
qu'il ya un problème est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec cette analyse là
alors moi je ne peux apporter qu'un
témoignage
vous êtes là pour ça les rats tout à
fait j'ai enseigné donc huit ans en
seine-saint-denis en collège et en lycée
et en huit ans je n'ai pas entendu ni
été témoin de propos antisémites ou de
difficultés puisque on en parlait un peu
avant l'émission pour enseigner la shoah
et une à une les rudes alors je dis pas
que j'ai pas eu de difficulté 6% je te
donne le sondage casser votre expérience
et % des agressions physiques ont lieu
dans un cadre scolaire 54 % des
agressions verbales dans un cadre
scolaire
oui alors je vous dis moi ce que j'ai
mais c'est intéressant aussi je rappelle
que vous avez enseigné tout à fait ça
veut pas dire que l'antisémitisme
n'existe pas parmi certains élèves au
collège ou au lycée moi je n'en ai pas
été témoin
mais ce qui me paraît important de dire
ce soir c'est que je crois qu'il ya pas
une véritable politique de lutte contre
l'antisémitisme dans l'école et dans
l'éducation nationale
on a longtemps cru qu'il suffisait de
parler du génocide pour lutter contre
l'antisémitisme comme si le souvenir
suffisait à à effacer un subconscient
français un inconscient plutôt français
ce que je remarque aujourd'hui et ce
dont on manque à mon sens c'est que
l'antisémitisme prend une nouvelle forme
sans doute chez des collégiens et des
lycéens
cet incident antisémitisme il se nourrit
de complotisme d'obscurantisme de vidéos
et en face on a des professeurs qui ont
des relations pédagogique en général de
confiance qui permette de rétablir des
vérités mais une fois qu'ils sont sortis
de ce cadre là comment est ce qu'on fait
et il me semble important que dans
l'éducation nationale on se questionne
sur qu'est-ce qui aujourd'hui nourri cet
antisémitisme et comment est ce qu'on
fait pour lutter autrement que par
l'enseignement de l'histoire parce que
c'est une forme de racisme qui est
particulière qui se nourrit
d'antijudaïsme qui se nourrit
d'antisionisme aussi a envahi voilà et
il a beaucoup se posent dans ce cas vous
dit on va on va venir parce qu'il ya des
tentatives de légiférer notamment sur
sur l'antisionisme quand il s'agit de la
négation les rails je me tourne vers
vous ce film et ensuite on ira justement
écouter un témoignage d'enseignants pour
rebondir ce que vous rencontrez il en
reste il en reste une centaine
qu'est-ce qui vous dise du moment qu'on
traverse les rescapés écoutez moi c'est
vrai qu'en tout cas quand il ya eu quand
on a tué des enfants juifs dans une
école
j'ai été glacé et surtout glace et que
personne ne descendent dans la rue parce
qu'il faut bien le reconnaître les
manifestations il y avait personne ça
n'a pas mobilisé et ça a été un des
moteurs parce que je me suis dit mais
qu'est ce que ces anciens déportés ont
bien pu ressentir face à ça est en fait
en les rencontrant si vous voulez ce que
j'ai découvert c'est que en effet et là
je vous tends d une perche c'est que ils
vont pas dans les lycées pour qu'on les
aime qu'on les voit comme des victimes
et qu'on arrête de détester les juifs
c'est pas du tout le propos
ils vont dans les lycées pour alerter
sur les mécanismes qui mènent à ça et
force est de constater qu'ils sont
désespérés face au manque de cibles et
de prise de conscience de cet aspect là
c'est à dire qu'ils ont l'impression que
les gens ne comprennent pas comment tu
viens de parler c'est un message
universel c'est pas un message pour
commémorer la mémoire des juifs disparus
bien sûr quatre ça mais c'est pas leur
objectif c'est vraiment des gens qui
vont
qui sont très âgés qui donnent toutes
leurs dernières forces pour aller
expliquer cette sophistication de la
machine nazie
la collaboration afin qu'ils ont été
dénoncés par la voisine qui était une
femme très sympa qui étaient copines
avec la mer voilà que la collaboration
c'est des tout petits actes et qu'il
faut s'en méfier que ce à quoi je lui
faisais rien dit parce que j'étais pas
juif à marc génis bas j'ai rien dit
j'étais pas comme il est tout à fait du
social démocrate et puis quand ils s'en
sont pris à moi y'a plus personne pour
m'aider
c'est ça et c'est ça qui viennent dire
en fait les déportés dans les écoles ils
essayent ils sont pas du tout victime
maryse ne sais pas te faire pleurer en
disant hé mais nous on a souffert c'est
pas le propos justement on va voir on va
voir un peu plus tard un extrait de
votre travail et de et de vos
documentaires on reste sur la question
de l'école et ça m'intéresse d'avoir
votre point de vue sur ce que va dire
barbara lefebvre que a rencontré maïté
frémont barbara lefebvre elle est à
l'origine d'un ouvrage collectif avec de
nombreux d'enseignants des territoires
perdus de la république c'était en 2002
déjà voici son témoignage celui d'une
ancienne enseignante
[Musique]
au collège il ya une part de provocation
mais il ya aussi une part
d'antisémitisme culturel qui existait un
certain nombre de nos élèves surtout
pour nous qui enseigne en zone
d'éducation prioritaire et on était en
première ligne
confrontés à la résurgence de cet
antisémitisme hitler a pas fini le
travail
il y en a que pour les juifs évidemment
avec toute cette thématique de la
concurrence mémorielle je peux vous
donner un autre exemple aussi si j'avais
un élève qui quand je lui demandais de
lire entre le mot juif
arrivé dans le texte il s'arrêtait il ne
voulait pas lire le mot parce qu'en fait
il ne voulait pas le prononcer tout fort
et je finissais toujours par j'essayais
d'insister et en fait il
il riait en me regardant en me disant je
ne prononce pas ce mot parce que ce mot
c'est un mot sale l'histoire de la shoah
si elle tombe comme ça comme un cheveu
sur la soupe je dirais ça ne peut pas
fonctionner c'est à dire que si un élève
depuis la 6ème jusqu'à la troisième n'a
jamais entendu parler de l'histoire du
peuple juif comment voulez vous qu'ils
comprennent soudain que en allemagne en
voilà donc l'enseignement que vous allez
dispensés et caricatural
si vous laissiez on n'explique pas
l'histoire longue de l'antisémitisme qui
prend ses racines dans l'antijudaïsme
chrétien aussi et qui va se poursuivre
avec leurs petits judaïsme musulmans et
bien les élèves ne peuvent pas
comprendre cela les élèves des milieux
populaires
c'est eux que vers qui l'éducation
nationale doit aller et c'est eux à qui
elle doit dispenser une instruction qui
soit la plus exigeante possible et
surtout en histoire surtout en
littérature et c'est là que la démission
est la plus grave la plus profonde et
tous les classements mondiaux le
montrent ces ces catégories populaires
qu'on a abandonné parce qu'on n'est plus
dans l'instruction on est dans le
zapping et la vague et éducation est un
petit peu dans le ludique clair bien de
mots meuse comment vous réagissez à ce
que dit barbara lefebvre au fond on a
trop misé sur l'enseignement de la shoah
une volonté d'en finir avec avec
l'antisémitisme
un petit peu ça rejoint un petit peu ce
que ce que dit ce que vous dites marine
russe est le devoir de mémoire
l'institutionnalisation de l'expression
je trouve ça un petit peu choquant de
d'avancer cet argument je pense que
c'est rappeler enseigner
ce qu'a été la shoah est indispensable
je suis pas absolument certain que ce
soit la seule raison pour laquelle
l'antisémitisme soit si développés et en
particulier je pense qu'il faut
réfléchir à des formes d'antisémitisme
différentes qui touche différentes
sociétés je pense que la france est
confrontée à sa propre histoire et
l'antisémitisme en france n'est pas le
même n'a pas la même structure que celui
que l'on peut trouver dans notre société
je prends un exemple vous allez tout à
leur diffuser le l'interview du
président macron et l'incident d'israël
je pense que le fait que immédiatement
dès que le président de la cre on a été
élu tout de suite on a vu rothschild où
tu t'en as vu les gilet jaune qui s'en
prennent à macron tout de suite on a vu
des des caricatures antisémites diffusé
été repris par le parti socialiste et
par d'autres partis politiques
immédiatement l'association soit faite
entre l'état rothschild les juifs
cela n'existe pas dans d'autres sociétés
comme l'angleterre ou les états unis
merci revient d'en parler avec les
corneilles noires oui c'est intéressant
mais je suis l'extrême gauche dit
capitaliste wallonia l'isthme religions
sont toujours là et elle se mêle à
d'autres j'en suis bien d'accord mais
corps bin c'est pour la première fois
dans l'histoire anglaise ce type
d'entité jean se fait jour en france
n'est pas la première fois c'est tout au
long du xixème siècle
il ya une spécificité propre à la france
dans et c'est aussi cet antisémitisme
qui ce qui nourrit une forme de rejet
on le voit par exemple dans le sondage
que je rappeler tout à l'heure 60% des
français associent les juifs à l'argent
dont il reste ce type de croyable vieil
antisémitisme texte oui bien sûr claude
gagnon vous savez tant d'une carrière
précédentes j'étais inspecteur général
de l'éducation nationale il ya eu de
très bons rapports à l'éducation
nationale a été fait là dessus les
choses sont très grave pas vous tromper
les choses sont retrouvés violente
concerne pas que la choix d'ailleurs
parlé des croisades c'est très difficile
parler des croisades dans un certain
nombre d'établissements car on ré les
vous avez des enfants qui réagissent
très mal qui sont même remontés par là
amis et vous avez des incidents très
graves avec des enseignants très grave
alors c'est très difficile d'avoir une
comptabilité encore qu'il ya un très bon
rapport rappelle plus le nom dur il
rapportera dans l'inspection générale il
ya une dizaine d'années a rapporté aux
ben voilà c'est le rapport obin sécurité
dans l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
il porte des cheveux uniquement de
france bien sûr mais là on avait de
belles analyses sur les départements
d'île de france parce qu'ils sont un peu
ça va un peu mieux mais le problème
c'est que l'éducation nationale est une
machine verrouillé et que l'information
ne remonte pas toujours je sais que le
ministre actuel essaye de faire remonter
l'information elle est très difficile
pourquoi parce que le proviseur souvent
ne donne pas toutes les indications à
l'inspecteur d'académie qui lui-même ne
donne pas les indications aux recteurs
et ça ne va pas ministère pourquoi parce
que il n'a pas envie le proviseur que
son établissement soit dégradée ça
l'obligé soit quelque chose que l'on
jette au cou
c'est très grave franchement en plus
vous avez à côté souvent de certains
lycées vous avez des dires des imams qui
mène la bonne parole quoi à l'extérieur
et je trouve que les professeurs sont
très courageux
arrivé au mondial quand même dans
l'éducation nationale il ya des et des
formations notamment pour l'enseignement
de la shoah
vous avez l'impression qu'on vous laisse
tomber ou qu'on vous accompagne pas du
tout et le les questions
que répète madame lefeuvre le faire
c'est des questions qu'on peut avoir
mais qu'on n'est pas obligé de tourner
tout de suite comme de l'antisémitisme
alors évidemment oui c'est à dire que
hitler n'a pas fini le travail
oui je j'entends effectivement mes dires
il reste encore des juifs
après ça est-ce que aimer ça c'est des
questions il faut pouvoir avoir un
dialogue avec les élèves
on peut pas dire un élève de troisième
tu es antisémite parce que tu as dit ça
il est en situation d'apprentissage et
effectivement c'est là où on apporte un
éclairage sur la façon dont il faut par
exemple et je vous pose une question
simple vous nous dites n'avons pas je
n'ai pas été témoin d' antisémitisme
dans ma classe on est après les
attentats oui qu'est ce qui s'est passé
dans la classe alors il ya eu 2 2
attentats très différents vous parlez
sans doute ce mélange de l'attentât de
charlie hebdo qui a été celui qui a été
sans doute le plus compliqué moi dans ma
classe je ne m'attends pas à méditer à
charlie hebdo et bataclan oui c'est ça
les parcs assurément non non mais non
mais aller et le j'ai eu d un élève ou
deux élèves qui étaient dans le
complotisme directement en disant mais
ça n'est pas possible et ça il faut il
faut l'entendre parce que pour certains
élèves
ça n'est pas possible qu'ils sont
peut-être qu'ils sont de confession
peut-être musulmane j'en sais rien moi
quand j'ai des élèves j'ai des élèves en
face de moi
qui ne peuvent pas entendre que des des
d'autres personnes qui partagent la même
des coreligionnaires puisse commettre de
tels actes
et ça je je je pense que c'est important
qu'on construit vous voulez dire par il
faut entendre parce que évidemment c'est
le rôle de l'enseignant oui ça se
traduit comment est ce il faut entendre
dans la classe on discute
oui déconstruit on discute évidemment
évidemment on est là on est alors c'est
comment on peut discuter sur
l'antisémitisme était son antisémitisme
ne vient y allait en faire alors ceux
qui sont pour ce maître de la et ceux
qui sont contre mais là ça dépasse que
venir discuter et je pense que c'est à
la barre à faire comme ammann attention
à ce que le rôle de l'école à l'âge de
l'âge des élèves qu'on a en face de nous
quand on parle de du travail de l'école
à l'égard de l'antisémitisme il ya deux
sujets en réalité il ya la nécessité
impérieuse de protéger les enfants à
l'école ce qui est une dimension qui
peut-être a pris du temps pour être
prises pleinement en considération à la
fois par l'éducation nationale et par et
par l'ensemble de la société et ça c'est
une des des dimensions des politiques
publiques récentes du ministère de
l'éducation nationale avec avec l'adil
crains c'est de permettre aux
enseignants aux équipes éducatives aux
proviseurs que que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure d'avoir à la fois des
possibilités de faire remonter les
incidents mais surtout et c'est le plus
important d'être accompagnés en cas
d'incidents racistes ou antisémites à la
fois pour comprendre ce qui s'est passé
pour mettre des mots qu'elles sont sûres
sur les choses parce qu'une des
difficultés c'est souvent que c'est
ainsi dans l'ain sont pas ne sont pas
totalement nier ou à oublier mais ils
sont maltraités ils sont maltraités
parce qu'ils sont traités comme des
incidents bano parce que quand il ya une
insulte ou une bagarre on va les traiter
comme une insulte ou une bagarre parce
que c'est compliqué de se rendre compte
que derrière cette bagarre derrière
cette insulte ya des préjugés et des
stéréotypes
il ya une attaque sur ce que sont les
gens ou iard un phénomène raciste et
antisémite donc ça c'est un point très
important sur lequel aujourd'hui
l'éducation nationale travaille à
outiller les enseignants les enseignants
les chefs d'établissement et pour ça il
ya un dispositif qui a été mis en place
qui s'appelle les
il ya une équipe nationale qui chapote
ce travail-là et une mise en oeuvre par
des équipes académiques valeurs de la
république
donc les bretons j'ai donc la république
mais des mes moyens quand vous disiez ça
ce que vous disiez sur bravo élèves et
vous cherchez pas par classe bien sûr à
savoir qui était musulman ou pas
musulman a pas donc établir des
discriminations ce qui paraît normal en
même temps le fait de ne pas tenir
compte de l'identité de chaque élève de
penser qu'ils sont tous sur le même
modèle c'est un élève standard fait ni
un peu leurs spécificités notamment
quand on est musulman continence famille
musulmans dans les pays du maghreb
le fait de dépenser et illimité beaucoup
plus répondu c'est normal ils sont les
pays qui n'ont pas de relations et
israël qui considère qu'il ya une
relation de guerre entre arabes et juifs
donc ça peut quand même être un truc qui
quand on arrive à l'école dans un milieu
où c'est à peu près naturel d'être en
conflit avec israël et donc avec les
juifs d'en tenir compte
oui j'en tiens compte jamais ça ne m'a
empêché d'enseignés beaucoup de chance
que je suis entré je veux dire que même
expérience c'est de la faute des enfants
ils n'ont pas du tout choisi ça mais
quand on est réalité de son sa famille
de ses pots de ses pensées de senlis et
c'est souvent les mots qui sont qu'on
entend dans la bouche des enfants
parfois on sait que ça vient pas
forcément de mais ça peut venir des
vidéos de la télé excusez-moi de leurs
parents 2 il ya plein de médias willy
lourd ça c'est l'école effectivement
c'est une loupe de la société c'est vrai
que c'est d'ailleurs le rabbin le grand
rabbin de france rennes cortial mais les
réseaux sociaux comme principaux
responsables sur la lieue d'impunité
quelques à lire dans le parisien va
terminer je vous donne la parole juste
après sa finale où justement parce que
je voudrais montrer un extrait de votre
documentaire de cette série hausse et
robert que vous avez rencontrées c'est
un épisode une rencontre un l'un des
rescapés racontent au foucault lui aussi
les confronter à des négationnistes
regardez j'ai commencé à témoigner
surtout quand il ya eu les
négationnistes ont commencé à déblatérer
a raconté que c'est les chambres grâce
était pour l'e book
c'était des décors de cinéma fait par
les américains tout ça ça c'était
c'etait deja comptable que ça pas existé
ensuite j'ai commencé à faire des
témoignages mais en général je j'essaie
de faire des troisièmes des jeunes de 14
15 ans quoi à peu près quoi l'âge que
vous aviez voilà alors ça alors ça
l'emportent par le salon parle plus quoi
alors j'ai reçu des courriers de l'aide
de machin de gosse et tout en misant
l'aide qui était très courte ou bleu le
jeune a écrit je réponds voulu être à
votre place
c'était sincère une autre lettre ou dans
la classe on était deux négationnistes à
la suite de votre intervention je ne
suis plus mais par contre mon camarade
lille est resté voilà des led comme ça
enfin une incroyable témoignage saut
final qu'est-ce qui le commet dire
qu'est ce qu'ils ressentent après avoir
témoigné phase avec moi voilà dans les
quatre fois que j'en ai suivi plusieurs
dans des lycées d'ailleurs notamment un
esther sono à sarcelles c'était très
intéressant ce qu'ils ressentent après
avoir témoigné avec moi je ne sais pas
c'est difficile j'en ai vu 25 mai en
tout cas ce qui est très touchant c'est
qu'ils me remercie vraiment beaucoup et
en fait ça me fait plaisir mais ça me
fait de la peine aussi parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont le sentiment de
ne pas avoir été assez entendue alors
ils ont été écoutés ils ont été entendus
mais ils ont vraiment ce sentiment ne
pas avoir été assez compris enfin c'est
l'impression que ça donne c'est qu'ils
essayent ils essayent ils essayent et
puis et puis voyez enfin ils sont robert
dans le dans l'extrait qu'on n'a pas
passé c'est que il dit que c'est pas
toujours évident de témoigner à l'école
parfois même certains proviseurs
n'hésitez pas le moment de venir
en fait ce qui se passe c'est que il ya
un filtre qui se fait c'est à dire
certains professeurs sont à l'initiative
des invitations de ces gens c'est des
rapports directs avec des professeurs
extraordinaires qui les font venir mais
tous les professeurs ne les font pas
venir et bas pour revenir à cette
anecdote de sarcelles c'était une
professeur extraordinaire qui
accueillait tous les ans des déportés
qui s'efforçait de le faire et ça se
passe et merveilleusement bien et elle
me dit mais vous voyez ici toutes les
communautés ça marche bien et tout ça et
je lui dis oui en effet mais vous avez
beaucoup d'élèves juifs elle me dit bah
écoute et non
j'en ai donc voilà enfin c'est quand
même pas par choix que tous les juifs
ont quitté le lycée public de sarcelles
donc c'est voilà c'est un peu une course
contre valgarde il faudrait qu'on
termine ce débat sur des pistes de
solution si on peut utiliser ce mot il
ya ce projet de loi cette proposition
doit ici à l'assemblée nationale je vais
pour pénaliser l'antisionisme on entend
le président de la république dire que
nier l'existence de l'état d'israël
c'est une nouvelle forme d'antisémitisme
on se souvient des injures
je fais un maquereau et des lapins voter
l'encontre d'alain finkielkraut pendant
le mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune traité
de sale sioniste de merde vous allez
répondre
est ce qu'il faut aller dans ce sens là
où au fond la ligne de crête est trop
ténus moi je pense que la vraie question
c'est à nouveau c'est la question de
l'état la question des pouvoirs publics
et dans le sondage qui a été publiée ce
matin et hier on voit très bien à quel
point les juges de france comme la
population en général nos fonds ne fait
plus confiance
nathan plus de l'état ne pense pas que
l'état puisse intervenir
on voit que l'état est tout à fait en
haut en bas en bas en bas de 2-2-2 de
l'élément de la gare celle ci devrait
comme un puissant première action c'est
de se plaindre au crif donc une réaction
que mais la terre entière on l'a
couvrant la piscine on n'a pas
l'impression que ça aurait été que
dorénavant une solution sinon vous
permet de faire c'était française c'est
l'état qui depuis toujours à protéger
l'ensemble des citoyens et il se passe
quelque chose depuis quelques années
c'est au fond la défiance à l'égard d'un
état qui perd lui même son pouvoir sont
précis fsa force d'action et on voit
très bien que la seule fille confiance
et est donnée aux maires des villages
exactement comme l'ensemble des français
aux associations de proximité au lieu de
proximité et c'est d'opter à la fois
rassurant et en même temps extrêmement
inquiétant puisque depuis toujours en
france dans la mesure où l'état joue un
rôle fondamental dans la socialisation
des citoyens
le déclin de l'état rend cette lutte
extrêmement difficile ça fait et vous
êtes d'accord avec ce sombre constat
parce que vous êtes député c'est sûr que
vous êtes la politique faut dire les
choses nous n'avons rien voter sur cette
question cette année après le discours
du crif qui laissait entendre beaucoup
de choses nous avons mis des mois dans
des à discuter d'une réponse à la
majorité ces propositions de loi sur
l'aisne en ligne un pro vient ici on
doit sûrement se donne à voir
nous non ceux participant du tout me le
président avait proposé de faire
effectivement un acte politique fort qui
pouvait être pénalisés premiers arrivés
on n'a pas réussi parce que l'assemblée
ne voulait parler de l'antisionisme non
je parle de leurs actionnaires
la résolution a été votée on a copié la
résolution du conseil de l'europe parce
que on n'arrivait pas à se dégager d'une
majorité à l'intérieur de la ferme est
terminée parce que député je pense pas
que ce soit le point essentiel le point
essentiel n'est pas un antisionisme lire
le sondage le montre qui reprend les
juifs de france ne craignent pas du tout
c'est assez cette question là il ne la
redoute pas elle est minorisé elle est
minoré les mineurs dans le sondage qui a
été propulsé cellier une scellier
peut-être mais ça pue politique
antisioniste antisémite c'est une cale
importante ce n'est pas essentiel on est
obligé de s'arrêter là je suis désolé on
reviendra et d'ailleurs c'est malheureux
sur sur ces questions dans d'autres
débats vous restez avec nous comme
goasguen
je vous faire écouter un aller le chef
de l'état regardez il va vous faire
penser à quelques mois tu dire in front
of me ok l'équipe 15 the city après
cette grippe les respecte je roule
travers force entre will not fun with me
à quand l ue ok sur quatre y body
respecte le rouge
voilà nobody provoque
nobody par le docteur habitudes en
anglais oui on a l'impression qu'il a
même imiter l'accent français jacques
chirac d'accord oui bien sûr c'est de la
com c'est de la com qui n'est pas utile
franchement je suis j'aime bien le
président discuté plusieurs fois avec
lui l'antisémitisme
ce qu'il a fait ne permettra pas
d'améliorer les choses
parler de cet incident la wii absolument
parce que je connaissais de lieux ans et
les histoires français chrétien du vieux
et bon élève il faudrait comme un mec
super et il je vais diriger le service
israélien de sécurité pression mais
enfin mais israël n'est pas un état
comme les autres
israël est un état où il ya des
attentats tous les jours où le problème
de la sécurité est un problème majeur
est toujours très facile de dire faites
attention faites attention non pour vous
il raconte quelque chose cet incident
dans l'hérault d'holnon la relation
entre la france et la balle je trouve
que c'est une comme un peu facile à
l'égard de ce café jacques chirac
je n'ai pas de sentiment que le
président la république et fait un
effort pour israël je ne crois pas qu'il
veuille en fait faire une politique pro
israélienne eh bien il a tort il a tort
car la france a un grand rôle à jouer
pour la paix et la paix s'acidifient
rapprocher israël de ses voisins plutôt
que de faire des zooms coeur disent
qu'il est anti israël est mal à la con
mais pour le moment le président de la
république n'a pas fait un geste
il n'y a pas eu de visite officielle
c'est pas une visite officielle un n'y a
pas eu de visite officielle d'état du
président de la république en israël je
vous rappelle que mitterrand avait fait
sa pub
c'est officiel le monde en un seul état
du monde entier seront mais moi j'aurais
voulu que ces deuxièmes fournissent
l'avion car en israël pour les ailières
tout cas physiquement mais j'ai un temps
votre argument vous attendez quoi au
fond d'eux des images et des mots qui
seront prononcées demain pour cette
cérémonie des 75 ans dont libération des
camps écoutez je vais dire quelque chose
d'où serait insolent que j'ai dit au
président de la république les juifs qui
sont morts en europe
n'empêche pas que l'on doive s'occuper
des juifs qui sont en israël
je trouve que c'est très bien de faire
ce qu'on a fait sur auschwitz et c'est
très bien mais je trouve qu'on a su
israélien oui jean louis fès 200 pages
bien sorti ça mais je vais oui donc
enfin bien oui ce sont des juifs
quand on parle des juifs chantant kearny
israël je lui ai dit d'ailleurs est ce
que vous êtes sûr qu'il y à des juifs en
israël car en parle toujours d'israël
mais j'avais des juifs d'israël
mais les juifs d'israël sont soumis à
des pressions considérables à vous
parlez moi je vais la géopolitique je
voudrais que le quai d'orsay change un
peu de politique
ça fait des années que je le dis je
trouve que nous avons tout à gagner à
avoir une politique beaucoup plus
ouverte la politique arabe de la france
s'est quand même passé un laurent fabius
a tourné la page bon ok allez on parle
un peu de paris parce que sinon on va
pas avoir assez de temps il reste une
droite parisienne parce que votre
candidat même des cirés écouter une
surprise moi vous savez je n'étais pas
très bien et cracher ta dati avec qui
j'ai toujours eu des reports difficile à
quoi attirer même couteaux tirés et je
trouvais que rachida dati il ya un mois
de septembre avait du courage car
vraiment je m'attendais à un désastre
je me suis dit s'ils n'ont pas un pas
deux candidats républicains à paris
alors là il veut partir et rentrer chez
soi parce qu'il n'y aura plus de droite
croyait vraiment qu'elle peut gagner
elle n'a pas de réserves de voix au
deuxième tour qui sont ces mêmes j'ai
pensé qu'on ferait même à 10% en
fonction des résultats des européennes
elle fait une très bonne campagne et je
le dis vraiment parce que elle est une
personnalité qui incontestablement a
mûri et qui marque dans un climat
politique qui est très très terne
parce que vraiment on peut pas dire que
ce soit d'une intelligence folle la
campagne parisienne pour le moment et sa
personnalité est passé et elle est
passée d'autant mieux que pour la
première fois j'ai l'impression que la
droite existe dans les arrondissements
du nord de paris
pourtant la droite parisienne elle reste
des idées en acier griveaux ses enfants
sont partis sont partis on n'a pas le
plus c'est plus la droite ça c'est sans
moi compris dans le 16e arrondissement
s'est divisée non ça nous divise et non
non il y aura une liste unie ce n'est
pas la division
les autres seront partout partiront il
ya d'autres listes à droite
oui ben ya toujours eu des listes à
droite mais bien sûr abella si vous
comme moi quand j'étais candidat là aux
dernières municipales j'avais quatre
listes dissidentes de beaucoup regardez
donc c'est rachida dati et l'année
d'algos oui auprès d'un peu dans cette
campagne
oui on a déjà brûlé tout intérêt à le
dire mais franchement je ne crois pas je
ne crois pas moi j'ai encore entendus
rachida ce matin et sa conjointe de
longue date même coaching je connais
tous ça fait 20 ans que le conseil de
paris ensemble et nous n'avons pas
d'animosité j'ai pas d'animosité à
l'égard d'anne hidalgo ch pas d'accord
avec sa politique je n'ai pas
d'animosité
le problème c'est de savoir montrer aux
parisiens que l'on veut le changement
alors on nous dit rachida dati est passé
à 19 % est ce que est ce que c'est
suffisant non c'est pas suffisant mais
c'est mieux que ne pas être à 12% alors
je m'aperçois qu'en réalité dans cette
affaire c'est griveaux qui a fait une
erreur parce que griveaux s'est fondé
sur les résultats des européennes on lui
a dit c'est pas la même chose et
maintenant ils s'écroulent avait écouté
chacun son provient pas encore perdiez
et reste de -15%
bon allez donc vous êtes le bruit et
l'odeur de la campagne ça vous aime pas
ah non au contraire parce que
figurez-vous pour certains néo ruraux et
bien c'est un problème
le député pierre morel à l'huissier veut
en finir avec les actions en justice de
ceux qui ont quitté la ville et nous
rejoindre dans un instant regarder
d'abord ce reportage tourné en alsace le
crottin de la discorde
c'est signé rabhi cas là on voit où il
croque regardez là là là bas là bas
l'abba secrétin madame hohler ne le
supporte plus ce cheval de trait vie et
fait ses besoins un peu trop près de sa
maison d'hôtes
si près qu'elle n'en peut plus de subir
les odeurs
mais pas seulement et nos hôtes se
plaignent des mouches surtout quand on
ment sur la terrasse etc on est assailli
par les mouches c'est pas très agréable
c'est normal qui trotte mais il faut les
ramasser
excédée elle saisi la justice en 2015
déboutée en première instance elle fait
appel la cour lui donne finalement
réseau verdict les viticulteurs devront
ramasser les crottins payer 2000 euros
pour frais de justice
hercules et leur clôture de 15 m moi je
suis pourtant pas les us l'un s'apprête
à exécuter leur condamnation la mort
dans l'âme et la coulée dans la terre
taux qui était coulé dans la terre voilà
dc dc mercredi donc dans deux jours on
va on va mesurer pour être bien précis
on va mesurer des 15 mètres rapport à
leur clôture
on va attirer 15 mètres et puis on va
faire un petit périmètre interdit au
cheval
cette viticultrice en biodynamique
depuis 25 ans ne comprend pas le
jugement de la cour d'appel s'est
entretenu c'est voyez autour de vous
c'est pas un champ de bataille c'est un
prêt c'est un verger agricole s'est pas
c'est pas un golf on va pas enlever les
vers de terre ou le micro morceau
crottin qui est à côté de mes pieds
c'est au contraire c'est ça qui fait qu'
il ya une vraie vie dans le sol
des querelles de voisinage comme celle
ci le maire du village y ait de plus en
plus souvent confrontés c'est des choses
qui aujourd'hui prennent beaucoup plus
d'ampleur que ça ne pouvait en prendre
dans le temps n'y avait pas ce genre de
choses on ne retrouvait pas ses conflits
de voisinage comme on le trouve
aujourd'hui les gens à accepter il y
avait d'ailleurs les viticulteurs
avaient des seulement des chevaux mills
avait souvent des des vaches à la maison
parce que c'était pas la viticulture
d'aujourd'hui et il n'y avait jamais de
problème moi je vois que c'est ça va
crescendo vraiment les gens ne
supportent plus quoi que ce soit la
faire du cheval sésame a suscité
l'indignation de plusieurs maires ruraux
une pétition de soutien aux viticulteurs
a même récolté plus de 16 mille
signatures
[Musique]
je connais du moins l'histoire ou la
faire et c'est scandaleux quand vous
voyez caunes qu'on nous gêne à ce niveau
là qu'en votant on pense qu'à des gens
qui veulent éradiquer les cigales en
provence m'envahit venir vance voir
d'abord et bienvenue c'est vous qui
portait cette proposition doivent d'être
député les les républicains du bas-rhin
et bienvenue à richard ramos député
modem du loiret ces sujets et me
tiennent à coeur également puisque vous
avez signé cette proposition l'ipad hub
à l'odeur pardonnez-moi de lozère la
lozère c'est très beau la lozère
pardonnez moi comment on fait comment on
peut comprendre qu'on en arrive là à
faire une loi pour protéger le chant du
coq le chant des cigales ça semble
incroyable dans votre reportage et le
terme intolérance on est de plus en plus
intolérant par rapport à ce que les
autres veulent faire et les activités
agricoles la vie des autres le milieu
rural je pense que beaucoup de gens qui
ne savent pas ce que c'est on croit que
dans la dans la nature y est le silence
et petites fleurs mais aussi de
l'activité il ya des bruits et des
odeurs et ça se mérite la compagnie se
mérite la campagne giresse que les
maires sont les maires ruraux sont
vraiment submergé de plainte
les maires sont portés de gifle ça se
dit et
je l'étais pendant 17 ans vous avez en
fait le juge de paix l'épreuve du
voisinage c'est la longueur de temps les
conflits d'usagé sol sac devient
impossible
un homme un coq des singles décrite que
feu tout mais les abeilles les âmes et
les déjections d'abeilles c'est du
pollen c'est ce qui permet de faire du
miel y en a un qui dit qu'il faut
supprimer ça donc il ya unanimité on les
imagine pour voter pour voter votre
proposition noire elle est très
importante a proposé sur moi je trouve
dans les villes les tribunaux auront une
jurisprudence qui est très inquiétante
parce que les tribunaux font dans le
voit avec vous avez eu raison de déposer
une loi parce que la loi ça va calmer
il ya deux façons de voir honoré
plusieurs mais on va pas faire une loi
pour ça
sauf que sauf que moi aussi qui suis un
élu rural
je dirais on est on est obligé et bien
sûr est d'autant plus qu' on a je dirais
avec des mètres carrés très cher dans
les centres villes et dans les
métropoles
on a accueilli des gens mais à bras
ouverts la ruralité ne mettront pas la
culture alors c'est que me réjean juste
expliqué nous c'est qui ces gens qui se
plaignent alors les bobos parisiens qui
s'en fout pote faut pas qu à rémunérer
c'est des gens qui n'ont pas la culture
de la campagne et donc ils veulent
imposer je dirais un mode de vie par
exemple vous avez vous avez le bourg
vous allez avoir des hameaux ou une
maison qui a trois quatre kilomètres du
bourg ils veulent la lumière jusqu'à
chez eux ils disent mais comment ça je
suis venu au village
mes enfants vient pas les chercher à la
porte de chez moi vous leur demandez
mais simplement bah c'est pas ça une
bonne odeur la barre sa une bonne odeur
quand c'est naturel d'accord et donc
c'est moins polluant que les pots
d'échappement dans les gens là dans les
villes non mais vous avez vous avez 400
maires aujourd'hui qu'en fait un panneau
ici il ya des coques des poules des
brebis il déjà si vous voulez pas passer
votre chemin
d'accord mais à quel moment vraiment ça
semble un peu étrange une plante elle
devient recevable
en gros c'est si le chant du coq vous
déplaît vous pouvez aller dont il est
bien sûr petit le tribunal autorise le
tribunal judiciaire
c'était tribunal d'instance les petits
conseils oui mais oui presque de juger
analyse
il regarde l'intensité la répétition du
bruit de l'eau d'heure et puis rapport à
la propriété
c'est très compliqué subjectivement
c'est très compliqué concrètement et
pardonnez moi ce qu'on manque c'est
quand même du bien vivre ensemble
dire que on voit ce ont réglé de façon
que je dirai à l'amiable mais même pas
l'amiable encore mieux que ça dans la
bonne entente
aujourd'hui c'est tout de suite on va au
tribunal
on voit bien qu'il ya un espèce de
durcissement et donc il faut retrouver
le vivre ensemble et comme on a des
communes rurales qui sont devenues pour
certaines des dortoirs
ça veut dire que finalement n'a pas
co-construit l'esprit village est donc à
la fois comme on n'a pas réussi à
reconstruire l'esprit village et bien au
mieux obligé d'en passer par la loi
en espérant quand même que l'on retrouve
l'esprit de village un peu partout il
faut nous expliquer vous allez faire
quoi précisément dans ce sac vous à les
recenser tous les bruits et toutes les
odeurs de la campagne où dit on modifie
un peu le code de l'environnement pour
intégrer la notion de son et d'odeurs et
ont créé vous avez les inventaires
régionaux les uns verte à patrimonio et
on intégrera ces éléments de fer qui
fera la liste des services régionaux
c'est des services ce sont les régions
qui maintenant au niveau de
décentralisation et là on va construire
un inventaire est quelqu'un qui arrive
dans un territoire et qui se plaît il y
aura une antériorité d'une
reconnaissance patrimoniale sensorielle
c'est ça c'est la notion même patrimoine
sensorielle qui va permettre au fond
comme par exemple l'unesco protège la
gastronomie
française c'est exactement là on aura le
patrimoine rural protégé ici l'unesco
veut le protéger sur le corps bio depuis
sa mort en préambule dans le plan local
d'urbanisme
on pourra rajouter au vietnam et dans
quels cas cette interaction sur une
commune et on pourra on pourra lui dire
regardez attention là là il pourrait y
avoir dix ans on pourra le mettre dans
le plan local d'urbanisme et donc ça
c'est très intéressant parce que ça
permet d'aller au conflit là où il n'y a
pas besoin d'avoir des des conflits
alors je pense que et puis comment
comment vous dire
je pense que c'est c'est l'esprit
français etc
moi j'étais pour qu'on garde par exemple
même à paris
quand on allait au bistrot avant n'avait
le bruit du percolateur qui qui broyait
le calme étant la plus c'est à dire le
bruit c'est pas quelque chose de
toujours négatif le bruit c'est quelque
chose qui répond un imaginaire mois dans
un bar j'aime le bruit du percolateur
tintin café
quant à café ce fait et donc ça veut
dire que il faut garder ça parce que
c'est à déshumaniser là c'est exactement
nenê la campagne donc le crottin de
cheval sésame protéger et oui le jugera
une base juridique a pris vie sur les
ânes interdit pas lé recours s'il ya des
siens bruit malicieux sylvian une
tronçonneuse assez tueur de nuire à 7h
du mat est intervenue aux noms mais
qu'on respecte la réalité intrinsèque
vous n'avez aucun doute ce texte adopté
unanimité la majorité elles mêmes les
parisiens ont joué là dessus
franchement enfin une white si nous
déclarions athlètes tous les groupes et
ministère la culture tout tout les tous
les mystères toutes les administrations
et le conseil d'état a donné un coup de
main bon et bien affaire à suivre c'est
la semaine prochaine le le vote on va
suivre ça merci messieurs vous restez
avec nous parce qu'il est temps de
retrouver
valérie brochard pour sa chronique et sa
journée très spéciale vous allez le voir
à l'assemblée où est-elle valérie ce
soir oui mais rien mais je suis
actuellement à 408 km de la terre en
direct de la station spatiale
internationale
mais j'arrive tout de suite pour vous
parler de l'espace
[Musique]
la vitesse d'une fusée bleue alors quel
rapport avec l'espace et bien figurez
vous myriam qu'aujourd'hui la commission
des affaires étrangères organisait une
table ronde sur l'espace et ses enjeux
scientifiques stratégiques industriels
et environnementaux un marielle de
sarnez la présidente de la commission
voulait être installé un cadre de voilà
un cadre de référence pour tous les
travaux à venir sur cette nouvelle
frontière quel espace de la surveillance
des satellites à la gouvernance du
cosmos un champ infini de deux questions
s'est ouvert ce matin et pour y répondre
la commission avait invité monsieur
thomas pesquet 10e français affecté un
vol dans l'espace figurez-vous qu'il m'a
accordé quelques minutes
eh bien les voici j'ai entendu la
présidente de la commission parler de
géopolitique de l'espace même de
désamorcer certains antagonismes
on en est là c'est le début de la guerre
des étoiles non c'est pas le début de la
guerre des étoiles mais ce dont on se
rend compte c'est que l'espace ça
devient un terrain de plus en plus
stratégique en fait c'est le sait le
sait pas un champ de bataille mais c'est
un endroit où ils peuvent s'affronter
des logiques public privé par exemple ou
des logiques d'appropriation ou de
partage des logiques de militarisation
ou de ou de maintien de la paix des
choses comme ça donc c'est de ça qu'on
est venu discuter le fait que
l'assemblée nationale s'intéresse ces
questions là qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce
que ça évoque pour vous le fait que plus
tard il y aura peut-être un ministère de
l'espace vous serez peut-être un jour le
ministre de l'espace non je pense pas
qu'il y aura un mystère de l'espace mais
on s'occupe déjà au sein du ministère
l'enseignement supérieur la recherche
des questions de l'espace c'est des
choses qui sont suivies de près parce
que l'espace et c'est par nature
internationale c'est évidemment un
milieu où il n'y a pas de frontières
donc quoi qu'on dise quoi qu'on fasse
dans l'espace on va être confronté et
bien au survol du territoire et
peut-être à une compétition une
coopération avec d'autres états c'est
important de suivre ça de près je pense
on parlait aussi pendant cette table
ronde d'exploitation minière de certains
astéroïdes
ça veut dire qu'on en est déjà là il ya
des mines sur sur crs sur sur david à
non pas encore alors c'est c'est encore
de la science fiction mais on s'y
prépare un de toute façon les sa note
travail à nous je pense que
techniquement c'est d'être prêt à des
choses qui vont arriver dans vingt ans
dans trente ans peut-être les cycles de
développement sont comme ça dans
l'espace un essaie d'innover d'être à la
pointe pour des missions qui vont durer
longtemps
nous on connaîtra ce à nous de notre
vivant oui oui c'est tout à fait
possible après on peut pas je prédis pas
l'avenir mais mais c'est tout à fait
possible du moins c'est ces cycles de
temps là dont on parle
prochaine étape c'est lié sait si j'ai
bien compris à l'été 2000 21 puis la
lune puis mars vous demandez à orly à 16
puis la lune c'est puis marc si je fais
les trois j'aurai beaucoup de chance li
ss on va y travailler très très fort et
c'est ça c'est à peu près du futur
proche donc ça devrait bien marcher
on espère toujours grand toujours un peu
l'hypothétique 1 dans le spatial ensuite
la lune est basse et pour on va dire la
décennie 2020-2030 on espère avec des
européens pourquoi pas un français ou
une française
évidemment parce qu'on voit aussi
sélectionner des nouveaux astronautes
donc j'ai du coup tout ça pour dire je
sais pas si moi je vous emmènerai par
contre vous pouvez vous inscrire à la
sélection et on essaiera de prendre le
plus grand nombre de personnes parce que
c'est pas avec moi que cette histoire
s'arrête elle va continuer bon je vais
tenter ma chance alors merci beaucoup
plus thomas parce qu'il merci on est
inscrits jeu nous inscrire toutes les
gauches nicolas baverez la direction
direction les étoiles bientôt bavay de
la rencontre
oui quelle concurrence quand même bon
dès la fin de cette émission très belle
soirée et demain
[Musique]